phrase how amazing was it for you to be
a part of this particular Disney's movie
well it was it was incredible because um
I mean for a few a few different reasons
I I grew up as kind of like a like an
obsessive Disney fan in general my
grandmother would take me to Disneyland
every single year we would stay for
three days I would do one ride per day
and just get right back into the line um
one year I only wore either
a Cinderella costume snow-white costume
or Alice in Wonderland costume so like
I'm obsessed with Disney and I loved the
Pete's dragon the 1977 version of Pete's
dragon in my family we would just watch
it over and over and over again my
sister actually my little sister when I
told her I was doing this she started
crying so it's like you know this is
this it's just it's it's really
meaningful to get to be a part of this
film and and to also be so moved by the
film and you know proud of it and
excited to share it with my kids it's
it's it's you know it's awesome have
your kid seen it no they haven't
no I only saw it my husband and I saw it
just a little less than two weeks ago
and well our son was at sleepaway camp
and we were like oh I wish he was here
but there for sure goodness he I don't
know if I'm gonna if I want to wait for
them to see it in the theaters like when
it's out or if you know I can maybe slip
them into a screening earlier but you're
also freaking with Robert Redford oh
yeah
and I had read that he had said that you
have a bright light in your personality
and it's such a joy just to be around
you because of the energy you give out
oh my goodness well ditto that's really
profoundly complimentary coming from him
he's a perfect human being I'd like to
say I mean he's he's he's a legend
he's probably one of the most
influential people in the entertainment
industry of all time not just
as an actor or a director but as an
entertainment entrepreneur with
everything that he did with Sundance and
he's an environmentalist and he saved a
horse on like the second day of shooting
like he literally saved a horse's life
and now he's like that that horse is now
going to be taken care of for the
remainder of its life and I mean he's
he's amazing and he's full of stories
and he's open and he's relaxed and it's
just like he's really handsome like he's
my he's my father
he's my father but and he's a natural
redhead I mean bonding yes the
relationship did you see any parallels
between Grace's relationship with her
dad and your relationship with your own
dad yeah you know I mean I think they're
very close I'm very close with my dad
and I think just having having a parent
who is a storyteller and who who
believes that magic exists in the world
and who embraces that you know the
possibility that anything could happen
that's that's an inspiring way to grow
up and that's that's how both my parents
are and um and then yeah and he would
tell us like stories for the movies that
he was working on when he was driving us
to school in the morning so to play a
character whose father is such a
storyteller is is such you know someone
who believes in magic and is so in touch
with their own childlike innocence it
definitely reminded me of my dad plus
there's the redhead thing of course um
you have a couple of other big things in
on the go
Jurassic world yes yeah I've said or do
you just start that up that's gonna be
happening next year sometime and I'm
super stoked I cannot wait it's very
cool and then I did a film called
gold that will be coming out later this
year with Matthew McConaughey
and then a project I did a episode of
black mirror that's on Netflix directed
by Joe rice so and aren't you gonna be
making your directorial feature film
debut or has that happened no no that
hasn't no I I direct a lot of short
content but I haven't done a feature
yeah and I and I definitely hope to your
dad has had such a prolific career what
are three of things that he's done
either television or film that you have
loved your favorite um probably my
favorite movies of my dad is um cocoon
might be my favorite movie and splash
and Parenthood I mean those but I also
have memories of being on those sets and
like trying on madison's like like you
know mermaid tail and putting the alien
mask over my head during cocoon and so
it's and like you know Parenthood was
just an insane blast because I was seven
years old and the entire cast was
basically that you know we were like the
same age and so um I mean it's it it was
definitely it's I admire him so much and
I admire him so much as a as a filmmaker
and a storyteller and he makes exactly
the kinds of movies that I want to be
singing in the theaters so I'm certainly
a fan